hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the London chest classic before I get
started with the game I just want to
make sure if the photos of the players
are in the correct place as in the in my
previous video I did about Caruana I
switch this place with certain
Kerrigan's so that was a bit confusing I
can imagine so this time karana
definitely has the white pieces and the
tournament did get a bit feisty er I was
actually considering showing you a game
between MBL and 11 Aragon but this game
now I was just ready to record the video
and in a decisive result so I decided to
show this one Carsten is still battling
it out with Wesley so at the moment I'm
making this video so who knows
I'll see maybe I'll show you both of
these games as well so corona definitely
has the white pieces and he plays efore
in five by and Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and Bishop to b5 the real opus we have
Knight to f6 the Berlin defence d3
Bishop to c5 Knight to c3 and castles
now be capture a Bishop captures on c6 d
captures on c6 and h3 not allowing any
Bishop g4 ideas and 9:37 what ideas of
getting denied maybe to g6 maybe the c5
in the future depends on what white
plays Bishop to e3 Bishop to d6 and
isn't interested in exchanging bishops 9
3 2 we have crook to e8 and g4 now
karana
starts expanding on the King side and
it's pretty obvious he's not going to
Castle kingside so nice to see 5 we have
nice to g3 now with a very nice control
of f5 and h5 probably with ideas of
bringing the Knight to f5 Knight back to
e6 and we have Knight to f5 and now this
is a beautiful square for the knight it
can capture the bishop on d6 pressures
g7 night to h6 it could be an idea in
some variations
c5 by aren't and now h4 a 5 on it now
starts pushing his pawns on the Queen
side as corona will probably Castle
queenside as well we have h5 and now
comes a very nice defensive and
attacking idea rock to a6 and this is an
attacking move but also it's a defensive
move this rock you can come to b6 and
the pressure b2 it can come to c6 and
you know help push the seat bone but
either way it's also guarding the entire
sixth rank so this is a very nice move
Queen to d2 Khurana prepares the Castle
queenside and we have a nice to d4
threatening knife casters I have three -
[ __ ] the king and queen so rock to h3
Bishop to f8 we have castles and now
Bishop to e6 what ideas of capturing the
a to bond King to be one defending and
we have f6 now c3 keeping the knight
Knight captures on f3 rock characters on
F 3 and C 4 and this c4 is a very sneaky
idea by Anand
this isn't with the idea of exchanging
Queens this is with the idea of winning
the game immediately if Corona played D
captures on c4 then Bishop captures an
a5 wins the game immediately what do you
play here if you capture the bishop then
this rook counts the d6 and you're
getting destroyed here you can't remove
the Queen you lose the rook you have to
play something like Bishop to d4 you
lose you're losing a piece and you're
losing the game but after Bishop
captures on f5 you can also decide to
capture the Queen but that then comes
this in-between move better capture c4
with check and also with an attack on
the f3 rook
so after King a1 simply rock captures
Queen rook captures and now Bishop
captures on f3 again you're down a piece
and again you're losing the game
so very nice mostly for by Anand Queen
to c2 by Caruana
now see captors and III rough captures
and III would attempt on the Queen Queen
to c8 and g5 now and Corona wants to
break open on the Kings side s captors
and g5 better captures and g5 and Bishop
to f7
attacking dh5 porn and if the point is
pushed also Bishop to g6 could be a
defensive idea
Corona does push h6 and we have G
captures on age six and this does open
up the King but it's much better than
something like g6 for example the night
simply goes back to e3 and from there it
can go to d5 at f6 and whatnot
so not really accomplishing anything for
black here Anand has the right idea idea
here G captures on h6 grabbing a pawn
kicking the bishop away and also the
rook on a6 is protecting the h6 bond so
this rook is coming really handy and
pretty much every variation in this game
Bishop back to c1 Queen to e6 so this is
move 26 and Anand is already threatening
Queen captures a two with checkmate b3
defending we have a for now busting open
the Queen side c4 b captures sorry a
capture some b3 a captures on b3 and
queen to c6 and this comes with a threat
of Queen captures on e4 first rope the
g3 check by Keira wanna King to h8 and
now look back to d1 now opening up the
Queen's protection of the pawn and also
what ideas of rock maybe 2 G 1 maybe 2 h
1 all the pens
b5 now Arnold is going all out and there
really isn't a lot of moves Corona can
do here he decides to go for c5 in an
interview after game he said that this
was his only option we have
b4 here and this before was a bit too
probably a bit too optimistic for Anand
he could have gone for something like
Queen captures on c5 but after Queen
captures and Bishop captures Anand is up
two points but Caruana can grab this
pawn but even better is rook to d7 and
White has much more activity and this is
compensation enough for the two points
so under the doesn't go for this
although this might have been better
than what on earth played after c5 he
played
four and now Khurana plays a Bishop to
b2 lining up this Bishop with this lone
King on h8 and already you can feel it's
a bit dangerous here hadn't played
Bishop to g6 and when when he played
this Khurana said that now he really
felt that he was better
what Caruana was expecting actually was
rook to a5 what ideas of rook captures
and c5 but he actually had a move
prepared for this Andrew k5 he would
play rook to d8 it's a little tactical
trick and now rook captures and c5
doesn't work because Bishop captures on
e5 would check and you don't really have
a move you have to capture rook captures
and you lose the Queen on the other hand
if you capture with the other rook then
rook captures on f8 with check you have
to block this Bishop to g8 and now rook
captures and this is checkmate
so after up to d8 you can't really
capture rook captures and c5 you'd have
to play something like Queen captures on
c5 but then rock characters on e8 again
threatening to capture so quinn captures
would check a team captures Queen and
now Bishop captures on the 8th and
probably f4 going after this pinned pawn
and it's actually white that's better
now but you know this is what Caruana
was expecting and he thought he'll be ok
here but after Bishop to b2 and played
Bishop to g6 and now we have work to
defy protecting the c5 pawn also adding
more pressure to the e5 pawn and Queen
to b5 was played by Anand and this comes
with a with a little trick if if Khurana
played the Bishop captures and if I
would check then Roger captures on e5
and you can't capture the rook if you
got the rook you get Queen to f1 check
now if King 2b to Queen 2 a1 is
checkmate and if you block with the
Queen that's that's a pretty much only
other option then rough day 1 check King
captures and Queen captures
with check you lose the Queen and the
game as well
so after queen-to-be five first erupted
the g1 and not allowing anand any tricks
with Queen to f1 c6 was played here and
this c6 wasn't it was just losing the
game I mean there are no better moves
for Anand but maybe rook rook 86 would
have would have given him more chances
now d5 phone is protected and maybe
black can hope for something here but
again after f4 you're still going for
the spin phone it's gonna be very hard
to defend this for Anand but okay after
work the g1 and decided to go for c6 and
Corona played Bishop rook captures on e5
rock characters 95 and Bishop captures
and e5 just comes with check you can't
block the check since the knight is also
guarding g7 so King to g8
and now comes Bishop to d4 and White is
still better here although in this
position Caruana missed a very nice idea
he missed Bishop to b2 he missed Bishop
to b2 this comes with the idea of queen
d1 and Queen to d4 now destroying black
over this diagonal but he missed that
after Queen to c2 he can't capture Queen
captures on c5 if you capture with the
Queen and c5 now then simply night to h6
check the King has nowhere to go you
have to capture with the bishop and
since the bishop was protecting the
Queen Queen captures in c5 you lose the
Queen and the game but okay after King
g8 Bishop to d4 karana thought he needed
to protect the c5 pawn but he's still
better King turf 7 by Anand and now
comes Knight to h4 and it's actually in
this position that we shortened Anand
resigned to the game and Khurana said
that he was pretty surprised by this as
you know there still moves to be played
maybe maybe he could do something but
Anand
agreed you know with himself that there
is no point in playing this position
white is threatening to capture the
bishop on g6 if black will recapture
then e v is coming and this G's
Square will will be destroyed stretch or
something like Bishop to h5 if you want
to preserve the Bishop e5 now opening up
the Queen's attack to the h7 pawn and
there's really nothing you can do about
this Queen TV - maybe black can activate
the Queen but after Queen captures on h7
King - a king - 8 and Queen to a5 it's
pretty much over queen is coming 3 6
black is black is getting destroyed
Queen way - does nothing here after
Queen to see a king to see one there are
no more moves for black and if if
instead after Queen to a5 I play
something like rook to 8 then rub the c1
King to c1 first a safe move then Bishop
to Bishop to f7 and after Knight to g6
Bishop captures on c5 and Knight to f4
black now really doesn't have any moves
to play if you move the Queen Queen f3
then e 6 is crushing and completely
winning but Anand didn't go for any of
this although as you can see there are a
lot more moves that can be played here
and obviously saw all of them and he
decided to resign the game after this
night to h4 was played so that was
Fabiana Caruana vs. Vishwanathan Anand
in round 5 of the London chest classic I
do hope you enjoyed it
if you if you'd like to see the game
between mvl and levin are onion you know
just write something in the comment
regarding that and I still have to check
how Carson is doing against the Wesley
so it's a pretty you know hardcore
endgame a pretty hardcore drone and game
with opposite colored bishops so yeah I
would like to thank max marriage
Brian Ruggles and Yan song for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
both of those will be about Google's
alpha 0 I hope you enjoyed those thank
you for watching and I will see you soon